[Music]
did you see our boy well by the way
Mercer's boy probably more than mine did
you see our boy again our boy again is
that a boy is at it again Jim Cramer's
at it again
so
here's Jim Cramer explaining and I [ __ ]
you not by the way seeing something so
absurd that the other host on the show
didn't even talk I want you to watch
this
okay he's about to say that some
authoritarian governments are actually
good you ready
all right Jimmy let's hear it let's see
what Jim has and by the way I guess I
really want to point out the silence the
stunning silence
and they gotta deal with what do you do
if you told people the way to beat this
is no vaccine and now you have a vaccine
so I think what you need is a propaganda
outside of the state infrastructure
exactly to start moving political
opinion but I think let me think of
propaganda we think about other regimes
that we didn't really appreciate
numbers
the stunned silenced now I want you to
watch the guy on the right right how he
uncomfortably shifts in his seat and
like moves his jacket around like you
can tell he's not he's it's physically
uncomfortable even being on camera with
Jim like like watch watch the guy on the
right I'll listen for the money here we
go here we go okay listen to the
mumbling I'll watch the guy this is
gonna take us a while to get there it's
only a minute and a half video but it's
worth it okay here we go you ready I'm
starting here for the beginning I'm
watch the guy on the right okay and they
gotta deal with what do you do if you
told people the way to beat this is no
vaccine and now you have a vaccine so I
think what you need is a propaganda
outside of the state infrastructure
exactly to start moving political
opinion okay first off I'm already
seeing him bite his upper lip I'm also
already seeing that it gets worse we
think about other regimes that we didn't
really appreciate
I told you that's that's something that
you only do if you're extremely
uncomfortable
Nobody Does that on television no only
do that when you're trying to Signal
quietly to whoever's watching in the
future like
oh I gotta I gotta I can't argue with
them but I'll just I'll do something
that like is a code later so if I ever
get canceled on Twitter I can go yo look
at me in that clip and look it up
clearly uncomfortable I am and how I
said nothing
okay okay here we go now I need you to
listen to the mumbling right but I want
you to see him see him realize or
leaving him out to dry okay and then the
response is hilarious here we go think
about other regimes that we didn't
really appreciate
you're like silent you're mighty silent
he said he mumbled your Mighty silence
he's like you're [ __ ] leaving me out
and then the other guy's not gonna be
dragged down with him and he says and he
says I'm just thinking about those poor
people stuck at Disney Shanghai Disney
for it's I mean it's the worst places to
be stuck but still cheap it's a real
small world after all
the other guy's like look I'm thinking
about the authoritarian government was
locking people to Disney and [ __ ]
remember [ __ ] the guys don't drag me
into this [ __ ] bro I'm not gonna be
[ __ ] on a [ __ ] you he was like we
need a regime change and we need to wipe
out our political opponents am I right
boys and like I think two of them are
like bro we're on CNBC
Jesus Christ
you know what I think do you know who
watches this bro day Traders and old
people checking on their retirement
that's it
dude I think
a a mixture or suspect a mixture of
booze and other things over the years
who's just turned his brain into mush
yeah